you want to know why he's a good shooter
ladies and gentlemen
he just came from the gym look at him
he's got his warm-ups on
shouldn't fall back 30 footers
good shot like that right center looking
good i think
i think he people don't realize how good
a golfer he is like getting fairways
striking like
he's a he's a tour he's a professional
level golfer
man hey steph yes what's up drake
nice shirt you got on i want to know uh
how many zebras had to die for you to
look fly
[Laughter]
wait you two know each other one two one
too many dre one too many but you know i
pulled this thing off so
oh you pulled it off i guess that's what
i'm saying i pulled it off i learned
from the best you know
yes sir he's a good one
260s trying to get over and does that
easily
it's a great tee shot in a great
position
for second shots here at the fourth well
good shot stuff do something good good
baby do something good oh good shot
baby i needed it very nice
stay right there in the flats i'm making
a three-shotter here what's up with
these stuff in these layups
all right here's curry see if you can
get inside his partner here
keep crawling solid come on
right together all right good shot thank
you you got this
tractor with top tracer presented by
capital one depending on this t-box trap
it sure is you lose your balance here
you you could be in for a while right
down this cliff
oh wow that's really good wow is that
good smoked
that that's nasty there it really is
oh settle down it's in the water oh my
goodness
we're in the water no it didn't yeah
wow how far is that how far is that in
the water
i mean it's hey it's like 400. uh i call
i'll call mj
yeah he deserves it he's a great glove
all right let's watch stefan here taking
manning's drive
all right middle of the green there for
stephen curry
everything matters here for curry and
manning
good shot stuff it's all in there
just outside of the pro one of the
better swings of the day for stephanie
free education right there
that's that's the good yeah
stefan's getting dialed in but maybe too
late after that
it's beautiful it is a scramble hole
remember